a single video on Tik Tok of a guy
drinking Ocean Spray juice riding a
skateboard listening to Fleetwood Mac
sold out every single bottle of Ocean
Spray in America I would call that
[Music]
effective I dat trade attention and
build
businesses Legacy is greater than
currency I'm a pure bread entrepreneur
for real for real for real like
documented
[Music]
the video we put on LinkedIn is very
different than the picture video we put
on Twitter that's different than the one
we put on Pinterest the creative is
contextual to the distribution but also
contextual to the psychology of the
consumer within the distribution what I
mean by that is Diana is herself but her
actual mindset when she's going through
her feed on LinkedIn versus when she's
doing that on Tik Tok is a slightly
different version of herself thus
rendering the creative needing to be
contextual by the way the way they did
in the ' 50s and 60s it was called radio
ads it was called print ads they were
doing it daily they were looking at what
was working and then they ran tv ads
we're doing what everyone's always done
we're just making pretend we live in
today amazing do that remember when I
created 211% off that 1% was like a
whole to do so the wine business in New
Jersey the way it worked was if you
bought wine it was the price but if you
bought 12 bottles if it wasn't on sale
you would get well first it was 10% then
before my time it kind of went to 15 and
you could mix and match if it's not on
sale some people made you have to only
buy things that weren't on sale we took
it a little further and said you could
buy nine bottles that are on sale and
three bottles that aren't and that's 12
and those three bottles will get 15% off
then what that evolved into is the
occasional occasional coupon that would
come in the mail that would take it to
20% off that was a system for a while so
one day like very early in my career I'm
like you know what I'm taking 21% off on
the case cuz it was like at this point
very established amongst us and our core
competitors in the general New Jersey
area when I tell you like everyone got
so emotional like we felt a huge influx
let's walk let's
[Music]
walk what's going on Yahoo finance fam
now you already know me you know I don't
do boats I don't do cruises however I'll
do a yacht especially if we get the
invite from Gary ve what is one of the
themes that's sticking out to you
today's marketing world is being great
at creative in social media social media
is building Brands yet there's no talk
of social media creative here there's
talk about television commercials that
nobody watches and there's talk about AI
That's not fully here yet to sum it up
there's a really interesting thing
happening here which is the big
opportunities for entrepreneurs and
small businesses and private
equity-owned Brands is the biggest
brands in the world are missing the mark
and in that is the opportunity and the
Arbitrage for the competitors
see you person thank
[Music]
you thank you everybody for coming we're
excited we're going to kind of do a
little bit of a half panel half podcast
session here I hate commercials on TV I
swear to God I'm Ling my wife is a
witness and I don't let her have the
remote control because she's not quick
enough is a minute and bottom said skip
I press it so hard I hope it's never
going to come back thank you Dad for
that statement I want to make sure I
just rewind what my dad just said when I
watch television at night from 11: to
12:00 I hate commercials the next thing
he said is when he goes to the
commercial as soon as in the bottom
right it hits skip I hit the button and
skip it my dad is watching YouTube for
the last couple of years and he just
referred to YouTube not television this
goes back to what I said earlier of
everybody saying Social is so young and
yeah for the kids it's good Gary but I'm
trying to sell the 69-year-old men this
is what I think people don't understand
is actually happening this isn't about
14 and 15 and 22 year olds the world is
transitioning into consumption the
future of Television is here everyone's
like Gary it's coming you're right it's
coming it's not coming people watch
YouTube and Hulu and Netflix and
connected TV and on and on and on I
don't know what people are thinking and
to Frank's Point live sports for sure
but what happens when ESPN becomes its
own Ott like it's happen
have a great can everybody my daddy
watches crazy [__] like World War II
like Nazi invasions he just watching and
cuz TV can't give you that every kid
watches YouTube over TV cuz it's better
his generation they didn't know now that
it's on the remote they know it's over
it's a wrap hey there man my man sit
down for a second I heard some great
stuff I don't know how to tell you this
this other than I can't believe what I'm
about to say is true in a Paris not a
hotel room but like somebody rented an
apartment for the week in Paris Gary
Camp who was the founder of something
called stumble upon I don't know if you
guys remember that said hey I'm working
on something could you imagine if you
could take your phone and hit a button
and a limousine would pick you up on the
spot and that was how Uber was invented
and I was actually literally in the room
there's an article ritten about it with
me in it that Gary veay that's what you
get out of stuff like get in here how
about marketers that are in the game
what do they need to do to actually
start to elevate their career to like
actually move up the ranks which you've
successfully done they need to
understand what they don't know I know
we sometimes say we don't know what we
don't know and so for example when I
went to Netflix I thought I knew what I
was doing in 2012 I was like I've been
marketing TV and film for 20 years and I
get there and I'm like oh [__] I have no
idea what I'm doing and then I just
instead of running away I grabbed every
engineer and said explain this to me the
humility to ask a question humility to
say I don't know what I'm doing and then
just keep putting yourself in those jobs
thank you so much thank you Gary always
a
pleasure you have so much time dud I
worked in a liquor store until I was 34
years old if I could just get you to not
judge yourself compare yourself and give
yourself kindness and patience Why Real
Estate CU you think you can make the
most money or do you [__] love it and
when you're done with University those
first 2 3 years whether it's proper
football or F1 or wine or sneaker I
don't know you but whatever [__] you
really love that's where you got to go
first because if it's a disaster after 2
years he'll be 24 you'll still be a
[__] child not long way short way the
happy way or the unhappy way of course
your mom wants you to be stable and be
in a good of course she loves you but
she doesn't want you to be
[Music]
unhappy
n
a